emma good morning how we doing okay so
basically i was anorexic during my
college years
and i've slowly rounded that corner
um but i'm still struggling a lot with
the regret and the shame for the time i
wasted
um especially now during like these
covid times
because i was already struggling to find
community and this year i was really
motivated to
try new things and meet new people plus
i'm graduating with my masters so
i feel like i should be excited about
the future
but i instead just feel like i wasted
all my young 20 years and because of
these times we're living in
i feel like i don't even have the
opportunity to pursue
like a career and friendships and a
romantic relationship
and i'm usually an optimist but i just
don't know how to find hope in this time
oh i love that question all right so
walk me back to college
how long did you struggle with eating
disorders
or disordered eating is the right way to
say that yeah
it honestly it probably started like
senior year of high school
and then it was probably a good five or
six years
okay and were you hospitalized was it
something that your friends and family
talked to you about or was it something
that mostly only you and maybe a college
counselor knew
about but that you knew weight on you're
pretty heavy
um there were times that i probably
should have been hospitalized but it was
just
kind of not something that i talked
about with most people
sort of thing and so when you say
rounding the corner
paint me a picture of what running the
corner looks like
um well like i feel like i've kind of
tried to be realistic
about like there just might be some
things that are always
residual in my life that i have to just
fight
on a daily weekly basis okay but for the
most part like i'm
in a healthy enough state now
that like i actually want to live a
better life
you know sure and did you work with
somebody
were you with a therapist or a
nutritionist or a group that
walked with you during this journey not
specifically
okay you just muscled it up and powered
through
yeah basically so what is a
new control behavior that you have
often when folks go from you know from
anorexia from bulimia from some of this
disorder eating from
overeating and they really just
grit their teeth and they power through
it often that behavior gets transferred
to a new controlling behavior
sometimes like another degree sometimes
a new job like a new
what's the thing that you focused on now
that you what's your default go to when
you're struggling when you're lacking
control
uh when you are feeling a little bit
spun out
um i i don't know
i mean i'm i still like i know that
perfectionistic side of me
is also the piece that like powered the
anorexia
so like i can feel it when i'm like
applying that perfectionism
in like work or school or something like
that and so how do you let the air out
of that perfectionism
how do you get back to a you you don't
fight the urges you can smile
you can talk to people how do you let
the air out of that tire
i don't know i don't know if it's
something like consistent
i think a lot of times i find like i'm
really close to my mom and my sister and
i'll just like call them up and just be
like
just talk through like that moment and
so i guess that's the only like specific
thing i could think of
very cool so i want to challenge you to
do a couple of things
and then we'll talk about the hope and
the optimism okay
okay so the next time well actually
before i do this let me ask you one more
question
in this craziness in this wackadoo world
that we're living in right now
where everything feels unpredictable and
we don't know what tomorrow's going to
look like and we had plans and now the
plans we just
watered them up and used them for
two-ply right are you feeling old urges
re-emerge
or are you kind of done with that
um i i think i'm kind of
done with it i mean there might have
been a couple of moments
where like the fleeting thought is like
oh that would feel so like i would feel
so in control doing that
and then i'm just like no but like the
place i ended up when i went
that direction was like a really really
bad place you know
okay so i need you to hear what you just
said do you realize how far down the
road you
are yeah that's a big
big deal i've met and known
and loved folks with disordered eating
challenges who
are unable to years past where you are
unable to wrap their head around here's
an urge
here's a way i can take control of this
moment right now here's a way i can
control
everyone around me but i know where this
leads so i'm not going to do that
that's a huge victory for you what a
gift
you've encouraged me this morning am i
just talking to you on the phone
first you're from houston and now this
that's incredible
um so i want to challenge you to do a
couple of things
one i want you to join some sort of
group
if it's a church group if it is a
a overeaters anonymous group and not
that you're an overeater but just a
disordered eaters
group whether it's a
professional women's group there in
whatever part of houston you live in i
know there's a number of those groups
there in town
and the reason is is i want you to begin
to practice relationships
and i know that sounds ridiculous
because that's just a thing we all
assume we should be able to do
i have to remind myself to go practice
every once in a while
i had a couple um and their kids over to
my house this weekend
and i realized that i'm out of it sounds
so
dumb i'm out of relationship practice i
haven't been having people over because
we
we moved we had covered wheels crazy and
it's just weird it's awkward
and so i'm having to re-experience it
and so what a group is gonna give you
is an opportunity to practice
re-learning how to be
human again okay so that's that's the
first thing the second thing is
is tell me what tomorrow you want it to
look like you said you were going to
have a lot of friends you were going to
have
this is going to be the year you're
graduating a master's degree
paint me a picture of what you had in
your head
i don't know i think i just i just
wanted new
like i'd just been stuck in the same
place for so long i just
i don't know i just wanted something new
and fresh and i wanted to like
feel victorious you know okay can i
can i reframe something for you
you spend a part of your 20s in a war
that cannot be won and you came out the
other side of it
you went to battle with the one person
you can't defeat and that's you
and you've come to make peace with who
you are
you've come to relove emma again you
have connected with your mom
and your sister because you're worthy of
being connected to
and now you're on the back end and now
you are walking through the world saying
where can i connect with others
i don't want you to think of your 20s as
something that you wasted
i want that your 20s to be where you
really tilled some hard hard soil
and now you're ready to grow and yeah
dude you launched out and you are ready
to be victorious i want you to tell you
you're a walking victory right now and i
don't know you from the men and the moon
but i can recognize a victory when i
when i hear one
you're a walking victory what you've got
to do now is
you've got to grieve this picture that
we had of 2020 it was going to be this
magic moment and
that we're going to do the roaring 20s
all over again and streamers were going
to fall from the sky
like when the rockets won the
championship or when the astros did
before we knew they were all a bunch of
cheaters
and um and you got to grieve that
picture
and then you just got to be about the
business of painting a new one right
what's your master's degree going to be
uh strategic communication
perfect and what do you what did you
what was your vision for what you were
going to do with a strategic
communication degree
um i wanted to do like the whole pr
social media management sort of thing
excellent which is something you
absolutely can do from the internets
absolutely can do in a wild whackadoo
monstrous city the size of houston
and so i don't think that i don't think
for one
stinking second 2020 is over for you
i think the victory's gonna look
different you might have to go back to
the starting line and go a different
direction
through a different set of paths in the
woods
but i before you head off i want you
just to exhale
emma and listen to this and if you're
watching this on the youtube i'm making
direct eye contact with you
you are a walking victory people don't
get to the other side of disordered
eating
with their urge their ability to control
urges to connect
urges with outcomes that's a major
step to then be able to be open and
vulnerable with their mom
and their sister to be able to go to get
a graduate degree and say i'm gonna go
help
other people communicate who they are
out to the world you're a walking
so i'm proud of you proud of you proud
of you you've got to get other people in
your life emma now
and and practice relationships and i
hope everyone's listening to that i hope
you're driving going practice
relationships that sounds stupid
you've got to practice relationships
you're sitting in front of the youtubes
all by yourself hanging out with just me
and be like practice relationship yes
you and you practice relationships
that's something that we've got to work
on especially in the time of covid right
and the last thing is paint a new
picture
and that's best done with other people
maybe invite your sister over call your
mom do a zoom meeting whatever that
looks like
and paint a new picture of what moving
forward is going to look like
let the picture grieve it let it go of
what 2020 was going to be and then
you're going to find peace
because you're a stud you're an absolute
rock star